this past week ubisoft were kind enough
to let us try out
siege's newest seasonal update now
there's a lot to talk about a favela
rework
a three-speed healer on defense and
numerous nips and tucks to things like
barrel attachments
bullet holes and oh baby the bearing
nine
here is everything you need to know
about north
star
okay so before we dive into things you
know the drill
like the video subscribe to the channel
and turn on notifications
because hey you like siege i like siege
let's talk about siege okay so first
things first
the new operator thunderbird she is a
three-speed
one armor defender whose primary gadget
called a kona
is literally an automated turret that
shoots out
darkstims it operates on a cool down and
like doc's stim heals or overheals
anyone who ventures into its area of
effect
this includes attackers it's also worth
mentioning that anyone who is in a down
but not out state
can crawl over to a kona it shoots a
stim into you and
voila you're resurrected so how do you
use it
well as far as walkthroughs go it's
pretty easy you put it on the ground
wait for it to charge up and watch as it
heals your homies
she gets three of them meaning that she
can pop say one on each site and since
she is a three speed with a frag heavy
loadout
take one with her as she roams off sight
to hold a choke
which brings us to thunderbirds kit now
in terms of primary they gave her
finca's assault rifle the spear 308
making her the only defender aside from
wamai
to carry an ar they also gave her cavs
auto shoddy which could actually be sick
considering that she gets the much
improved bearing 9 as her secondary
which we'll touch upon when we talk
about barrel attachments
she also gets legion and ying's pistol
but
who cares for her secondary gadget you
get to choose between a nitro cell
or impact needless to say it's likely
that she'll be played as a kind of
jaeger-esque put it down and forget
about it type roamer
it's also likely that because of that
she'll be
pretty popular and ranked the point is
obviously to go
kind of nuts with her since she outputs
healing whether or not she's alive
so naturally i gave her to our new 18
year old video editor told him to crush
a g-fuel and said
hey eat up kid
okay chill that said thunderbirds kit is
very versatile and i could actually see
a universe in which
on certain sites you could run her as an
anchor
think about it you've got spammable self
healing an auto shoddy
a nitro cell and a truly excellent
smg which segues us perfectly into the
next subject of interest
barrel attachment changes in short
ubisoft have both
reworked and simplified barrel
attachments such that they actually
well make sense in addition to you know
hiding flash
the flash hider is now strictly
responsible for dampening vertical
recoil
the compensator continues to mitigate
recoil from left to right
and the muzzle break helps recenter a
weapon more quickly whilst one tapping
the suppressor remains
entirely useless which makes me really
sad because i was really hoping they
would do something with that
anyway this obviously impacts certain
weapons more than others
most of the already easy to use guns
felt pretty much the same
i didn't notice much of a difference
with ying's lmg or
sledge's ar for instance since they
already boast a relatively low rate of
fire
twitch drones after uh
crazy that said there were some
notoriously unwieldy weapons for which
it seemed to make a
huge difference such as the f2 now don't
get me wrong this does not hold a candle
to the
old pre-nerf muzzle plus acog f2
because that thing was but this new one
with flash hider
not too shabby dude this thing is so
hard to control
yes
but where the barrel attachments became
most noticeable for me at least
was on one particular machine pistol the
bearing 9
whose recoil has been foobard for quite
some time
now i'm not sure if it's just because of
the attachments or if uv rebalanced
machine pistols specifically
but man does this thing go burr that
said there did
also seem to be some recoil nerfs the
most noticeable of which
was ash running either flash or
comp her r4c felt unexpectedly
unwieldy and by unwieldy i mean
unwieldy like we're talking something
along the lines of the recent jaeger
nerf where even with the hollow
the kick was just incredibly noticeable
they also
took away that third ash charge that
they just gave her
so rip ash i guess
next the map rework favela honestly when
it comes to siege maps
it's kind of just impossible to make
real
substantial pronouncements this early is
it better than it was
[ __ ] absolutely is it good
who knows the biggest difference is that
they removed a ton
of the external walls making the map
much
closer to being well you know playable
it's still pretty clowny though that
said it continues to be hard as [ __ ] to
see
anyone on the damn thing and it still
feels as if there's tons of
weird tight claustrophobic choke points
plus i don't know about you but
i still can't load into this map and not
play like an
absolute idiot
the next big change is the stuff that
happens post-death
one absolutely massive quality of life
upgrade is that ubisoft
finally took out client-sided bodies and
implemented a kind of
translucent valerant-esque operator icon
in their stead
this means that when you die your body
just fades away
instead of becoming a highly annoying
meat shield they've also
re-jigged the post-death sequence
somewhat making it a little more
apparent to new players how it is they
got fragged
and what will happen in the seconds
following the kill itself
next are some very big changes to the
support mode that were unveiled earlier
this year
namely being able to use drones and
cameras
after death now to be clear this is only
coming to the test server
not the live build so before you start
screaming at devs on twitter about how
the game is dead
please register the fact that this is
only being
tested not implemented
tested so yes you heard me you can now
hop on
any previously deployed drones after
death and drive them around as if you
were alive
yokais twitches mozzies you name it
you can also hop on cameras which
includes maestros
bulletproofs etc speaking of
bulletproofs they're now able to be
rotated and have been equipped with an
emp shock that can be discharged
by yes dead defenders in terms of other
small but
significant quality of life changes they
got rid of bullet holes
meaning that you can no longer clap
someone through an imperceptible hole
that you made earlier in the round
i think i speak for everybody when i say
thank [ __ ]
god they also made it so that melusi's
gadgets are no longer bulletproof
this one's pretty straightforward and
let's be honest
long overdue yubi also finally got
around to fixing the game's
smoke propagation system so for
technical reasons that are way above
my head and i have no hope of
understanding toxic babes can no longer
clip through walls and deny
plants in the dumbest ways imaginable
last but not least and this one's really
interesting
they've made it so that you can melee
mira windows
maestro cams and bulletproof cams and
render the actual glass
impossible to see through needless to
say
this is going to make these things way
less oppressive the cams are still
usable
mind you like maestro can still open his
camera and go pew pew
but he now has to be super careful when
denying plants or hard breeches
playing strictly off of intel and sound
cues
so on the whole a pretty great update
not game changing by any means but
great aside from the fact that i'd wish
they'd just gone ahead and added player
outlines
if cs go can copy it from valoran so can
you ubisoft
i think that northstar is a step in the
right direction and i for one
can't wait to see where they go from
here
inside you can go for it
come on get him for the views man he's
right there
oh my god